all right darren huff returns to las
vegas with the show no limit at the
venetian jillian sat down with the
dancing with the stars judge to talk all
about the show plus she puts him on the
spot with a fun mirror ball themed game
[Music]
welcome back to las vegas we're so
excited to have you here how does it
feel just to have a headlining show on
the las vegas street it's amazing it's
you know it's crazy i used to come here
as a kid all the time walk down the
strip and see the lights and the signs
and think maybe one day i might have my
own show here and
and here we are it's pretty incredible
derek huff no limit is truly limitless
when it comes to the music and dancing
to have all the different genres you
know it's like motown and big band music
or contemporary or
spanish argentine tangos
rock and roll i mean literally every
different genre you could possibly think
of in all different styles of dance as
well
and an incredible cast of dancers that
are just
mind-blowing derek dances sings plays
instruments and brings the audience
along for the ride my goal is just to
come out here and put on an incredible
show with high energy
and just make people you know have a
great time timing is everything when it
comes to the quick costume changes in
fact the backstage um you know situation
choreography if you will is is very
active lots of quick changes and uh yeah
it's it's a lot of fun though yeah
there's a scene in the in the show where
you can't find your pants and i would
imagine that's actually something that
really does happen from time to time yes
yes
i brought us all right
i was going for a mirror ball but you
know it's like vegas style it's colorful
okay cheers it's filled with some bubbly
we're gonna play a game called sip or
spill so i'm gonna ask you a few quick
questions and you can either spill the
answer and answer the question or you
can take a sip and not answer it's kind
of like you please the fifth i got it
you ready okay tell us the most
embarrassing thing that has ever
happened to you on stage
wow
um or while performing
okay i'll just do one my first season on
dancing with the stars it's the second
episode i'm dancing with jenny garth
live in front of 22 million people
i do this little move and i drop jenny
garth no on live television thanks for
spilling that one next one speaking of
dancing with the stars your favorite
dancing with the stars partner
that's a tough one i can't i can't say
my favorite i can't i'm gonna say i
thought you were gonna sip on that one
dream roll you could do anything what
would it be dream role
dad
what is your favorite role of all time
that you have played
my favorite role of all time
myself cheers
just because honestly most of the time
the things i've done is you know it's
reality tv right dancing stars or world
of dance so i'm just being who i am what
has been your favorite interview today
that make sure everybody's gone
you yes yeah that was the answer i'm
looking for derek thanks for playing
sipper spill thanks for being a good
sport this is your vegas souvenir a
vegas style mirror ball just for you
cheers derek congratulations on
everything the show is awesome we're so
happy to have you here thank you so much
appreciate it
cheers to that was fun you can see derek
have no limits now through september at
the venetian with shows wednesday
through saturday tickets start at just
45 dollars and you can purchase them
right at ticketmaster.com